[Music]
double-decker buses men and top hats
guys we have officially made it to
London and jetlag is real we're
exhausted so I got this coffee to
hopefully give me the energy to blog yes
we are vlogging all week long as we're
here to cover the royal wedding and
today we are going to see all the major
sights of London to start off
immediately
right across the street from our hotel
isn't another than Hyde Park I'm gonna
get caffeinated and frolic about
hi guys i'm lauren zima we are here at
Hyde Park in London we have made it to
cover the royal wedding and I'm going to
ask a few people what we absolutely have
to do over here oh where are you from
they're from Spain okay we tried thank
you everyone's a tourist there come more
people with suitcases great do you live
around here what are three things that
we have to do while in London in London
go to Buckingham Palace go to the houses
of parliament see Big Ben and stuff like
that and go to some Paul's Cathedral
High Parks over there no no this is
Green Park Wow
screwed that up thank you we weren't
even in the right Park crap hi guys i'm
lauren zima reporting to you from not
hyde park so we're going to go find it
apparently it's over there all right
we've gone from a mistake to a full
emotional meltdown we are on Diana
Princess of Wales's memorial walk so now
I feel great about this complete
directional mishap you want to learn
about England so maybe we just casually
jump into this tour that we didn't pay
for know that Mike is too conspicuous
I'm in heels so this man is going to
help us what was your name sir
Alex Alex taking us to Hyde Park thank
you Alex okay great
thanks Alex
so Alex see you have to abide by the
regular rules of traffic okay he does oh
here we go
my panther loving this put a wide-leg
trouser is not ideal for bike trap so
Alex what's to the right here is that a
wellington arch to the right wonderful
we're seeing London from Alex's bike
that's it we made it well thank you for
the trip can you what who's your
favorite royal Prince Albert let's throw
back okay thank you
thanks Alex we made it
when in the Rose Garden literally stop
and smell the roses here in Hyde Park
the Queen may have her throne but you
can have a [ __ ] look who caught up with
us
the Tor bet they're wondering how we got
ahead of them are you guys wondering
where we were missed us yes it is us
we're back you were learning are you
wondering how we got over here
we took a bike mm-hmm much quicker than
walking Oh how's your tour going what
have you learned the most important
thing what's your favorite thing you
learned Oh
[Music]
Hyde Park is beautiful the sun is
shining but we've got to check out
another quintessential area of London
Piccadilly Circus we've heard that there
are tons of Prince Harry and Megan
Markel things to see there and maybe
even buy and one thing you must do in
London guys hail a black taxi cab
or a bus
we're getting in one an actual black
do people here have the sense that the
royal family is moving forward I think
so with the Prince Harry definitely bit
bit bit more than his brothers all the
brothers a bit more traditional but I
think carries a bit more down-to-earth
so do you like it yeah yeah he's okay
seems a nice guy now that I've met him
but I'm looking for a pint if I bump
into him while I'm down here
after a big day in London we finally
made it to one of the recommended spots
Buckingham Palace of course they won't
let us in but it's no big deal
we'll see the Royals at the wedding on
Saturday thanks guys keep watching for
all of our awesome rail content we're
going to be interviewing some major
people this week check it all out at ET
online.com and on our youtube channel
and of course watch Entertainment
Tonight